let's do this let's do it whoa all right
pumped as well all right five four three
two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are sitting down with Eric Matzner
howdy what's up brother thanks for
coming out of the show greatly
appreciated for having me as you guys
know we like to take very complicated
subjects and make them more relatable
for people and inspire you to build with
them so today we're gonna be talking
about nootropics we'll be talking about
enhancing the mind we'll be talking a
bit about climate ocation as well some
sustainable climate change yes yes yes
so let's start unpacking so you've been
doing nootropics now with your company
neutral and you guys have been doing
this for four years now that's correct
yeah so yeah we started you know back
four years ago nootropics were much
lesser-known but they were kind of
coming out of the internet where the bio
hackers were picking up where science
had left off in the 70s the research had
originated and but a lot of it while
there was someone healthy people kind of
didn't really focus on totally
optimizing like work productivity or
memory and learning in healthy people
and so when these forums kind of came
together they started putting all this
knowledge there but it was very
difficult and to some some extent it is
still fairly difficult just properly
source where you know what you're
getting back then everything came in
like mylar bags direct from China and
you're like am I gonna like die from
taking this so people would group
together and do purity tests and things
like that things like that and so that's
kind of where neutral my company came
from was to do the test you need to
order a certain quantity and then you
need to it doesn't make sense cuz it'd
be multi year supply or like that you
would even the quantity to get tested
sometimes so centralize that by doing
that and also allowing me access to the
patented pure ingredients that
individuals couldn't get themselves
either
hmmm this is this is interesting there's
this whole birth movement that was
occurring GC in the 70s
well the nootropics originally came out
in the 70s but the real biohackers and
these forms and Longy City and subreddit
sort of nootropics came about in like
the last five or ten five five to six
years so that's like more of location
nootropics earlier in 70s but then the
biohacker movement and all this
subreddits and everything very more
recently 5-10 years but I really this is
renewed this is like 40 years of just
being like how do we enhance the human
mind with nootropics and this is an
exciting time of like you said putting
together the right and testing to
testing that over and over again on
different people and seeing what ends up
happening let's actually go through some
of the science yeah and what you and
what you pulled up because and what
you're gonna show us and teach us today
because I think this kind of is a good
segue into it yes so I so I just wrote a
book or I'm in the process of finalizing
it's called the history of nootropics
from plants to piracetam so I like to
like lose a part one there's gonna be a
part two is about all the different
nootropics part three is about like the
ethics of human cognitive Hanson but
this one focuses on like why do
molecules that plants make work in our
brain how have they shaped the course of
human evolution and then how did we get
chemistry how did plants affect other
molecules affect history and change the
world I think a lot for the better and
then how we got to nootropics
it's kind of like the the gist of it so
if you want to jump into that let's go
ahead I love the idea that humans ate
plants and that the plants altered our
mind and certain plants would in the
cance our mind
so yeah let's dive into this let's dive
in so if we look at the human brain is
that the first well the human brain yeah
the human brain started is in evolution
there's fits and spurts and so in this
whole of the first we should pull up the
first slide yeah and so if we look at
something called exaptation which is
this other this is a product yeah
you gotta you got the next one is also
it's the back is at the backside the
next one the next slide or so one more
and then okay so that's gonna be the
other so what is the new trophy yeah so
this is like what I cover in the book
but it's just a nootropic out there is
so it's something that enhances learning
and memory while being safe and
protective of the brain has to be like
non-toxic and also I prevent you from
concussions or strokes when you lose
oxygen and just being towards higher
level cognitive ability which we'll go
into in a bit so let's roll the next
slide here and and yeah it being
non-toxic like you said it's crucial
it's crucial if if so there's a
difference for the cognitive enhancer
nootropic real quick is that a cognitive
enhancer could make you smarter right
now well you take it but kill you
tomorrow it would still be a cognitive
enhancer whereas a nootropic if it has
negative side-effects not a nootropic
anymore gotchas so like a nymphet amine
a nymphet amine yes
leaves you worse off with lower dopamine
levels and kind of strung out because
you flush out the dopamine instead of
recycling it so and in fetta me like an
adderall or something like that is not
considered a nootropic it would be
consistent it's a central nervous
stimulant among other things but also
maybe a cognitive enhancer but not
necessarily nootropic it's not a two-way
street is if not non-toxic exactly all
nootropics are cognitive enhancers by
definition but not all cognitive
enhancers are nootropics so we looking
like the evolution in the human brain
size we can pinpoint actually that human
brain evolution was spurred by our
ability and access of marine resources
meaning fish with the molecule called
DHA and so DHA is like part of fish oils
DHA and epa and DHA is a limiting factor
in brain size so if you look here this
is the amount of DHA for different
animals and so you can see like how
squirrels are high schools or hogs are
small and they're eating like nuts and
things on their eating yes what you have
DHA which have some DHA a Venegas in
them and the but the we cannot get from
grass we as humans can't extract the DHA
and so we eat animals that eat algae or
the fish for example but like cows are
ruminants they have four stomachs they
eat grass they vomited up something
called cud and they
and they get the DHA and that's a we eat
a cow we get the DHA out of it but what
happens is the protein in animals or
bodies grow but their brains stay
relatively the small size so humans are
and out of an example where we keep hide
DHA content or brain and if you looked
actually a dolphin would be somewhere
right here like right under humans
because they're eating fish all day so
their brains have grown in a similar way
interesting so the part of human
evolution that has to do with us fishing
and eating the DHA oil in fish yes had
to do with what specific aspect of brain
development so this is so in evolution
most people talk about survival of
fitness but exaptation is this idea that
something occurs and then what flows
from that
so because we had fish resources and if
you look at humans typically we have a
savanna hypothesis which is like we were
in the savanna no we're actually the
aquatic ape hypothesis went a little too
far but it's much closer to accurate you
look at humans we don't have we have
sweat glands we have we do not have we
have Savannah dwellers do not have sweat
glands they don't have subcutaneous fat
they don't they have fur to reflect the
sunlight we don't have that we would be
poorly surviving in a savanna so if you
look we also things like I don't know
what your timer I got some I got some
reflections you could reflect but if you
look at like weird things in our biology
that tell us that we definitely spent a
lot of time evolving water when your
hands prune for example it's not because
you're like in the water too long is
because that increases your grip so
that's an evolutionary yeah at the point
of the fingers becoming the proof is for
the increased grip or friction yeah when
you're under waters we were like hanging
out in water hunting in water if you go
to Africa all the animals have to come
to the water and you just kill them
right there so I made a lot of sense
that we can't go that far from water you
don't have giant containers and ways
transfer water dig wells so it makes
sense that humans stayed by the water
and then which is where we evolved from
and the reason captured fish exactly
mentally exactly so our brains grew
and then from that you get like symbolic
consciousness where we start making art
and music and all these things our brain
is growing so much that it has like
extra nutrients till I do extra stuff so
you'd say like the DHA is DHA and aar
there's two limiting factors and
anachronistic acid has another source
DHA really can only be found in like the
grass and in algae and in we cannot eat
grass and get it so that's what causes
like huge growth in our brain you would
attribute a decent amount of the
evolutionary like are we talking over
what's equal we're talk we're talking
about from almost where we get to Homo
sapiens is like from this 15 you think
there's a book called human brain
evolution yeah this is where this chart
is from and so is that one that you can
and it's like if they're like pretty
certain that they're pretty certain the
part of the evidence the great thing is
that when we live by the shore the
settlements got washed away so in the
archaeological evidence they don't find
a ton of things by the rivers and by
they've washed away so but there is a
large shift in the understanding of
human evolution based on available
marine resources and if you look at
what's needed in the human brain this is
the only way you can get it is why you
need a lot of fish so let's roll in
that's right human history so fast yeah
so then we go back we're gonna go back
in time a little bit to like the plants
and we're gonna look at where plants and
humans are all eukaryote plants animals
are all eukaryotes so we share this
common ancestor and a lot of the major
genes in our body we share with those so
we have 23,000 genes 3400 go to that
same ancestor so similarly with the
plants there's 3,000 of this common ones
and that's like where our body regulates
the different neurotransmitters plants
use neurotransmitters the same ones we
have to do different things and to like
cause chemical reactions and do things
you're not really like thinking per se
but if you imagine they have to take
sunlight and grow and convert and stuff
if you hit the next slide there's
actually a cool chart here and so the
plants are in this like epic struggle
between herbivores eating them and
between like they need to be pollinated
most of the plants are dynast amaura
they have seeds that need to be mood or
pollen that needs to be moved by
bug so there some bugs are helping them
some animals are helping them and some
are trying to eat them so they're like
don't don't eat me and then this like
spread my seed and then some of the
insects will help the seed get exactly
so like a good example is like caffeine
for example is a molecule were gonna
look at more in depth but caffeine for
green like for like worms and stuff it's
a poison so when they eat it it's
short-circuits our brain and so for but
if you look at like the flowers and like
places that where the bees go when the
nectar is of there's lower levels of
caffeine not enough to like kill the bug
but just what is what is caffeine doing
us boost our memory gives us a nice
little buzz so the bees are getting an
extra buzz and they're buzzing around
going to the plant and that memory
enhancement actually makes the plant the
bug remember where it got high and it
comes back to that plant so there's a
that's but it's also again a toxin to
the lower level bugs so it's doing this
dual purpose and usually kills worms so
it kills the lab but it stimulates
colonies yeah okay and then you know we
had a Matthias on our show
he was really interesting he was
engineering bees to become more to
become better at their jobs oh yeah I
saw that guys the presentation indeed by
anybody
yeah interesting it's super interesting
to train wild animals to be more
effective or Africa what were they
giving them they're giving them
something or doing something to change
their behavior yeah I don't exactly
remember but how freaking interesting is
the bee as part of this ecosystem and so
wheat the from the neck the nectar the
pollen has a little bit of caffeine yeah
well in the parts of the plants yes
where it's getting that nectar so the
that molecule slots in the bees brain is
actually very similar to ours and
there's papers about how be an insect
Brett be brain specifically can be used
in studies to mimic as mimetic for a
human brain so there's there's those
slots that it fits into are very similar
like adenosine is very similar in shape
to the coffee molecule and I believe by
the way the one point before I go here
is I think we have the pictures of the
images in the next slide is like if you
look at other drugs for
example like heroin can you go back real
quick so you look at like heroin for
example the opiate in the plant what are
the do in humans it makes us like sleepy
not hungry you don't want to procreate
so if you have a bug as a predator and
it's coming to eat you and you now
drugged it so it doesn't reproduce it
doesn't become hungry it does the exact
same thing in bugs that it doesn't
humans that's why I don't recommend take
an arrow and it's literally trying to
eliminate you from the gene pool and
stop you from being productive so when
you talk about it that way then that
makes a little bit more sense of why
those molecules are made and you can
kind of see that in almost every so
those are called secondary metabolites
those are things that the plants are
making that aren't necessary for their
there to live which is like a primary
metabolite speaking of wealth inequality
and speaking of people being very
addicted to heroin and being more just
like you know and not wanting to
reproduce or not wanting to make some
make something into the world and that
being a reason of of their genes getting
out of the pool
that's pretty crazy it's kind of wild
it's kind of wild because we have some
of that going on right here in SF yeah
you can trace like all the drugs is a
blank book called plants in the human
brain that has a Kennedy as the author
has all the different plant or drugs and
why the plant makes it why it slots in
our brain so you do go to the next slide
now you can see that adenosine looks
very similar to caffeine and then shape
wise and that the simple way that
caffeine works to keep us awake is that
adenosine is like a bank deposit of
tiredness and when your bank account is
full you're tired and so your brain
while you're awake it's constantly
releasing adenosine receptors and as
those slots are all full then you go to
sleep and that's what happens the
morning no adenosine exactly the guys we
set it basically that's part of why
caffeine stops working on you as you are
like a wake for a long time so once a
caffeine molecule goes in there blocks
the adenosine and so that's why it works
and so if you look at these shapes we're
going to see in a little bit you go to
the next slide
is that so coffee
so some slides missing here in general
from the book but but coffee so the
history of coffee real quick is that it
was found in Ethiopia in the desert
there's a couple different origin
stories yeah got about a goat herder who
was out in the thing and his goats ate
these berries they got super energized
and so he like was like what is this and
that's coffee or a guy who was sent to
his death in the desert he found the
coffee plant got so stimulated he's able
to survive and then that was like a real
you know religious thing Wow so kind of
like made its way in the Arab world but
they don't allow alcohol and it was
lying there for that first moment of
like understanding coffee and caffeine
and now caffeine and coffee is all over
all world they're like two dollars for a
little tiny cup at every single
restaurant in cafe it's pretty nuts how
cops oh yeah so that the way that if
that happened is the coffee
so it was like banned on and off in the
in the middle in Africa and the Muslim
countries and then it went to like
Amsterdam and then it made its way you
know they have one plant couple plants
only they got started getting it and
they bred them then eventually when it
makes its way to England it actually has
a huge effect like in London and for
example prior water which are drinking
right now we can praise water then we
have clean nice water here but in the 16
1700 s walk pure water was a luxury and
so the town Wells they would have like
dead bodies they didn't know about
microbes and germs but they knew he
drank the water you would get sick and
it would be like tainted and so people
used boiled or fermented drinks and so a
lot of times people were drinking
alcohol all day when you beer like low
dose beer low dose wine I was like the
drink of water so ever you can imagine a
city everybody's drunk before lunchtime
and so like this is what when coffee
comes here's in the 1798 there this guys
are saying here's one in 1660 so the
coffee drink hath caused a greater
sobriety among the nation's whereas
formerly apprentices and clerks with
others used to take a morning draught of
ale beer or wine which by the disney
dizziness they cause in the brain being
drunk made for many unfit for business
they now use the good fellow and this
wakeful and civil drink
so coffee was the great coffee the sober
drink the mighty nourishment of the
brain which unlike other spirits
heightens purity and lucidity coffee
which clears the clouds of imagination
and the gloomy wait which illuminates
the reality of things suddenly with the
flash of truth so coffee literally
brightened us it brought us the
Enlightenment if you go to the next
slide here because we used to also drink
4:00 in the morning when we were because
we didn't have clean water and then that
would you make us actually more cloudy
for business and for trying to build
things versus coffee which wouldn't keep
us very alert and vigilant and building
these things so this was a major ramped
up in productive major change in
productivity but then that what schools
the societal effects occur because of
the culture of the coffee at coffee
houses so whereas before you'd go to
these like dark bars and be drinking now
you're going to coffee shops and getting
drinking the coffee being stimulated and
having conversations and instead of just
like being drunk a mala Bois you're
actually like stimulated and the people
together being stimulated more and so
you can actually trace like Newton's
theory of gravity relatively príncipe it
comes from a conversation started in one
coffee shop continued in another one and
that's how we got three of gravity
Lloyds of London the insurance market
was originally was a coffee shop new
Jonathan's was a stock exchange there
was a place called Jonathan's that got
kicked out like screw you we're gonna
make our own new Jonathan so each coffee
shop had its own kind of like vibe to it
and like there was times when we didn't
even have names for different like
fields but it was like everyone in that
coffee shop is like doing weird math I'm
doing like weird like physics and so you
kind of would just go there and there
was like newspapers were named after the
things as well and they would distribute
them there and what was cool is that and
why they became like a Stock Exchange
typing place is because anyone from
different classes a guy from the
especially the class Society you
couldn't the lords and the nobles
wouldn't be with like the lower level
people excuse me
and the when you know the coffee shop
the sailors would come right in from the
port smelling like fish and gross and
sit with the businessmen and do deals
and so they became these places of
exchange and there's like centers of all
sorts of awesome stuff yeah I
of the history of coffee and how it
ain't ramped up like productivity and I
just really love immersing myself into
older time periods in history because I
kind of romanticize at least living in
them for a short bit of time just so
that we could really experience what
went on in those times because how
interesting would it be to be without
the phone in the computer and all the
satellites everything for just a little
bit and just sit there and just observe
what people are engaging in the present
moment and how their went to France you
could have hung out with Voltaire Locke
and dinner on and Franklin we're all
hanging in the same coffee shops and
artists and a lot of things were going
on so this was like a central pivot
there's even next slide I don't know if
we have the war one in here but coffee
in the Civil War was like the the South
was blockaded and they didn't have
coffee and they didn't know the caffeine
molecule what what exactly it was they
knew that the plan had something in it
but they were there's some argument that
like the South lost the civil wars they
were like drinking dirt they didn't have
any coffee and they were like trying to
find a caffeine stimulant whereas like
the North in part of the rations was
coffee and hardtack which is like a
bread they would like dip into the
coffee and that was like the rations
every day they were given that there's
more references in letters home from
Civil War soldiers referencing coffee
than bullets or like anything like
fighting related like they were like it
really spread the habit out and so
around this time okay what yeah okay
that's how we actually get so this is
another cool side history note of how
pursuit of one thing got us something
else as so and so at the time we didn't
have organic synthetic chemistry and so
colors were made naturally so purple was
very expensive it was like mollusk
shells that had to be like fished then
ground up and only the Royals could
really use purple like war purple and so
around this time the queen of clean uh
and France wore a purple dress and it
also happened at the same time the first
tabloids that were like being
distributed around Europe so when that
dress and that color like made
in everybody was like I want this how do
we get it so there was like a scientist
went and was like should I make quinine
for malaria or should I make a color
fortunately he took here he chose a
color and that color became mauve and it
became purple and there was like a race
to the Patent Office to get it done and
and how did synthetic chemistry of the
color purple give birth from coal I
don't know we have a slide with all the
different molecules you have a slide
with molecule shapes next next there so
they remember that denizen receptor and
that caffeine they here al al azhar is
red Lera Zin is red it is just like
those molecules so the molecules that
were getting from Kolya mean so in coal
antara means they were like taking out
and there's like dark purples and blacks
and then Reds in there and so they
looked very much and they found that
some of them have like drug properties
they would do these things so in making
those colors they started like figuring
out some of these molecular shapes or
processes and they would do a chemical
reaction it would turn out red it would
turn out purple and so they started
having these like racists the Patent
Office so in Germany and coffee from the
fashion color this is separate from
coffee this is sepia we've moved on from
the fashion color from the color purple
started this organic chemistry yeah but
what led to the color purple what was
the coffee - purple coffee was separate
was just like how the molecules affect
us then in around the same time in 1790
1780 so synthetic color or synthetic
chemistry in color it was is different
from it's different um coffee sorry that
was missing a few slides for this
shortened talk here but so yeah so this
is the next twist which is how in the
history we're going from like what we
had in plants that were good to now can
we start making our own things for the
first time molecules that may not exist
in science that we're gonna synthesize
so they started making those colors they
found and so what happened is in much
more effective way synthesizing yes
synthesize the name is setter from the
natural sources and so they were like
races to the Patent Office like red was
like they gave the patent to two groups
because one was like the night before
and one was the next day and so they're
like [ __ ] we need to scale up our
process and so they went to the
universities like scientists like we'll
pay you to figure
the next colors the new colors and that
is what started the industrial drug
design process that's still in effect
today and if you look at like all the
German chemical industry companies from
Bayer - myrrh and all these other ones
they all started in Germany right around
the time making colors making colors
patenting colors patent oh she can't
patent colors well you could then
because they were like new structures
and they were like they were
synthetically made and so you could
practical bayer won the 1905 Nobel Prize
for making indigo making indigo for
making indigo but today no more color
paths I'm so I'm sure they're still
color patents out there I mean Pantone
sells colors and there's patented colors
of different stripes trying to use color
like to make that gold bottle I have to
give a fact that's a custom color that I
is like made in a paint factory and
actually every time they do the batch it
comes out a little bit different so it's
like color is very hard to translate
color globally so I have a Pantone
system which is kind of crazy so how do
you communicate a color to somebody it's
a picture as different lighting it's
like that blue and gold dress like you
never know let's keep us let's keep on
this so we go to the next thing so we
got so I like just in that one some of
that is that in pursuit of fashion which
you can make you know people try to
belittle fashion without fashion and
pursuit of like that creative creativity
in color in life we would not have drug
development so don't ever let anyone
talk down the importance of fashion okay
that's a good point there you go and so
what's scary are weird when you start to
look at neuroscience and just science in
general is how early we are and like
relatively new like the word
neuroscience wasn't used until 1963 at
MIT to describe a lab there so we're
like 50 years into 50 something years
into neuroscience and so in 1950 they
discovered gaba as a neurotransmitter so
the quick things we're gonna talk about
neurotransmitters a bunch is that a
neurotransmitter is how the brain fires
from one sent out across the synapse to
make something happen to make a
connection in the brain to cause a
cascade that flows through the brain and
so most of them stimulate on and tell
the brain to send a signal on and so
this thing that was called factor I for
inhibition was like the first know
inhibitory neurotransmitter this guy and
Florrie discovered at Earth's Florrie
and so they were like trying to figure
out what the heck this thing was and so
then they isolated it finally in 1963
they figured out that what it was they
called a gaba and then we go to the next
slide and we see labs all around the
world working on creating derivatives
that were patentable for inhibiting the
brain such as a sleep aid so this place
in Belgium UCB Pharma they were
synthesizing all different derivatives
of this and one of them called UCB six
two one five became known as piracetam
so it's a cyclical derivative of gaba
meaning they modified this existing
neurotransmitter and got out this nice
little to occupy related een structure
so we go to the next slide we can see so
when you're making a molecule you're
saying that they went directly to sleep
first well cos gab was inhibiting so
they thought it was related to sleep and
gaba is implemented implicated in sleep
in some ways as well but they thought of
this stops reactions as this slows down
maybe we can make the brain go to sleep
so but when they do these things and you
see b61 v was one in a number of lines
it's like LSD 2525 has nothing to do
with the chemical structure it was a
twenty fifth version derivative or or
got that they made so then you get a
formal name only LSD doesn't really have
one and so this is one of the studies
that they did on the batch of chemical
quick stop at neurotransmitter as well
so where does the initial pull the
initial pulse or signal co2 the first
neuron that fires because then the GNAT
neuron will send the neurotransmitter
across the synapse to the other neuron
which will then cascade the signal so
when your brain receives information
it's trying to integrate it into like
the basis you have of your like your
your neural structure so if you know
about neuroscience my brain is gonna
like activate those neurons and start to
branch out from there and even as I'm
repeating this it's firing to like link
together the information to bring up the
next word that I'm gonna say are those
neurons where do they hold the
information for your nose that's up for
debate just last week they they took a
snail and they chalked it and then they
took mRNA out of it
another snail and that snail acted as if
it had been shocked so it's it's not
entirely clear exactly where a memory
exists although the like memory for
example is formed in the hippocampus in
the sub ventricles own there's these
like beautiful neurons that like seem to
be involved in wayfinding and like
remembering where your camp is
remembering where that lion is you know
so that in evolution you would not make
a mistake it was like that was things
that would stick out seem to be much
easier to remember where I was like the
prefrontal cortex the front of our brain
up here seem to evolve later and that
was for more like theories of mind where
I'm thinking like what am I going to
tell Alan tomorrow like that's thinking
into advance it's like a kind of
different area yeah so near the
hippocampus there's more of this for
this path of like where is the
information where am I gonna go and
fight exactly they figure it out and
then versus pre photos like playing yeah
and just things to remember so here's
one of the experiments that they did I
kind of want to take a nootropic you
take one yeah get in there I should I
could Rio
so I'll show you there's the two so here
we have two different formulas in mine a
gold and a silver and so yeah that's
good and so the gold so the gold is
something called new pack which is a
thousand times stronger than piracetam
and the silver was something called
phenyl piracetam which is a these are
beautiful by the way okay so these are
well-done Walden's their custom not
artificial colors and yeah we'll put
them up the reason they're gold and
silver is because when I first started I
didn't have the scale to have custom
non-official color capsules made and I
used actual gold and silver flakes
that's why the bottles gold and where
the gold standard is because it was like
we're high-quality and I was like
importing gold from this German company
that gold stronger gets our gold from so
yeah these will make sense to explain in
a little bit but if you want to be a
little bit quicker I would go with the
silver one if you want to be like deeper
into the focus I'd go with the gold one
way all right so you want to go deeper
so it'll take a little while to dissolve
but hope probably by the end of the
they'll be active and you can you'll
show a cat corpus callosum and we'll
show how what's going on in your brain
activating the second but so this is how
they discovered the memory retaining
properties of the brain which is they
put these rats in a little cage just
quick I know this is gonna get us deeper
into science I just want to make sure
that people at home know a little bit
more about what just happens so these
you guys are selling right now yeah and
there is it 50 but 50 to 60 bucks
described as you take a one time bottle
one time one bottle is 35 pills or 30
pills 30 30 15 gold 15 silver and gold
15 silver and then and then alternate
between them you everyday you alternate
between gold and silver and then the
gold and silver are slightly different
formulas and we're all well unpack this
yeah packet I think it's better to go
into that when we get to the slides that
show the destination check this out
because you know one of the most
important things to do in your life is
to treat yourself like a science
experiment because if we're gonna be so
so cautious all the time and never
attempt any sort of quantified self on
us we got to try things see how it feels
and how quantifies in us and then just
go forth and change if we want to keep
doing something maybe we don't how do we
want to augment and enhance the human
mind as we do it so you know always be
willing to at least try something and
see how it seems safe I mean you have to
me I'm like II need your die trying and
I try some experimental things where I
have to use this equation in my mind
where I'm like based on the evidence I
see here is this thing possibly gonna
increase my risk of mortality
cuz I've taken like an extract from the
pineal gland that like potentially like
regulates your biological clock and I'm
saying to my followers on Instagram
wherever like if you want to know this
works follow me for the next 80 years
it's like it's it's concert' you have to
be careful but at the same time I know
that if I do nothing I'm gonna die I'm
gonna age I'm gonna like to generate and
so at some point like if they're over a
peak of your activity during the day
like taking
nootropic may actually help you execute
faster and more thoroughly and give them
more things done during the day so time
is the most valuable resource and if you
can achieve more in less time than other
people yeah that's very impressive or
even in the same time if you can achieve
more in the same time as other people
that's also very impressive that's what
I'm a big believer in meta learning
which is when people say what do you do
with your nootropics I say I learned how
to learn and so I read books at first 20
hours I don't learn anything much more
rapidly I've increased I look at the
limitation on computer systems is i/o
input and output so I learned how to one
of the first things I did when I was
increasing my brain as I started
relearning at a type I got a Canisius
keyboard and I type 150 I'm a 99.9% I'll
typist like a type 150 words a minute
easily 130 peaked like 180 if I'm really
at it and then I also learned how to
speed read whereas at which we did we
did where the average reading speeds
about 200 to 300 words a minute and
college press was about 500 and you saw
me hitting like 900 mm which is like
keeping up with you a little bit like
600 yeah it was me buddy clean at 600
not to take away from your achievement
but with a little bit of training where
you go faster than slower so even faster
than a little bit more slower and kind
of can wrap it up and this is the word
just appearing like the of an to which
I'm there yes the rapid serial visual
presentation RSVP reading and there's an
algorithm by company called spritz where
they like added pauses after periods and
commas so they made it you can go even
faster which has been knocked off by
everybody which is great so there's
plug-ins for your phone there's browser
plugins and so there's like spree derp
and speed-read you know you can find
this technology and use it for some
links to show no we'll put some we had a
spotty we can show it input-output was
the most important kind of things and
you can learn and if you're learning how
to learn faster and you increase your
input and output you can now learn
anything at a very rapid rate and so any
skill you want to learn is it becomes
more surmountable and the nootropics
actually help you with learning and
memory who's what we're gonna see here
even when it's interrupted is that these
so these rats go in a cage rats will
always go to the dark
as part of the cage so he put the
ravenous cage then they like lock him in
they put it or they put this red light
on and then they shock the foot and so
they like it's like a zap and the rats
like [ __ ] and so if you put them in
there in the next day when that light
goes on if you get the heck out of it
he'll get out of the dark area but if
you shock their brain convulsive shock
at least dude people in mental
institutions or you give them a
suffocate them which is simulates
hypoxia which means a straw a stroke
causes damage in the brain because you
lose oxygen and then there's a glutamate
induced neurotoxicity there's this whole
process of memory consolidation that
doesn't occur and so they found like
when they suffocate the rat for example
it only remembers 20% of the time to get
out of that area when they gave them
porosity and prior eighty percent so
they're like what the heck is going on
and when they when they did the
convulsive shock it's not again less
than 20% but if they gave the rat
piracetam prior to the shocking the
convulsive shock a hundred percent
retention they're like what the hell
next slide what the heck is going on
here so they pull out this UCB six to
one five they're like let's run more
tests they do 30 different classical
psychopharmacological tests as you can
see here they found no sedation
tranquilization no stimulation no
interference with synaptically
transmitters no acute short-term or
long-term toxicity they found like none
of these like weird changes it only
seemed to affect like higher-level
activity and when they would like
suffocate them and then see how long it
takes their brain activity to go back to
normal which is associated with higher
level activities like the first thing to
go when you're suffocated they found
that it took like 30 minutes in the
control and 17 minutes in the rats who
had passed am so they realize [ __ ] we've
got something on our hands here so this
is 1963 54 55 so you being a rat
piracetam before it gets shocked or
electrical also shocked or suffocated
and then it's when when it's revisiting
the light and the darkness where the
area where they get the shock or the the
whatever the it is they will actually
have a much higher rate of not going
into that area if they use Perez act
before hand which is so interesting
because what are these what is piracetam
what are these new nootropics that we
can use in these situations they didn't
yeah so they were like what the heck is
this next slide so this is another one
they did this is where I was talked
about so this you just took a new pet
which has an even stronger effect on the
corpus callosum so the corpus callosum
is the main highway between the two
sides of your hemispheres of your brain
and so this is a cat's electrical
activity this is the control just like
when wah-wah-wah here's this is 15
minutes here's 30 minutes look at 60
minutes in 90 minutes
you see want want want want want so
that's like much more information
circling throughout the networks of the
brain that makes sense more information
circling throughout the networks of the
brain communication of your brain is
increased across that main highway
there's more traffic going on your brain
correct so you're drawing from area
different areas your brain and bringing
more information so my question would be
then have we went under EEG this is this
is there are EEG studies single-dose and
Akita long-term and there are changes as
well I don't have those in this these
slides but there there are effects and
then and then under EEG we're looking at
more brain activity across hemispheres
across them yeah the brain then without
piracetam or without new pepped in this
yeah I actually did a my in equals one
study I had a journalist come and we
went to a doctor or scientist and they
put an eq EEG headset on and went in the
control her brain had like a lot of
activity like an outside and like it was
like read on this graph which was like
bad and then after the new pep and then
30 minutes later her brain was like calm
it was all green and it was like
integrated you had like alpha the better
alpha waves and stuff like that is neat
obviously needs to be replicated but
it's pretty cool I want to put you in a
daily study with the EEG and neural I do
I do my own meditation and I wear an EEG
headset I get biofeedback yeah yeah
there's that but I mean like let's do a
study with like a thousand people that
I'd love to you you have the funding
let's let's do it because I want to see
this yeah let's let's get an X next
slide anything for this yes so they're
like what the heck is this where does
this fit into all the drugs we know and
this is a the system of psychotropic
drugs that was known by
like the early 1970s and 80s and so you
had cyclone elective cycle epics like a
dis Leptis where you have like the
psychomimetic switch wasn't what they
originally called psychedelics before
psychedelics term was well-known so
that's in that own category there yeah
because it meant simulating psychosis
actually if the read of Michael Pollan
book he talks a lot about these
categories and so you can see the
central nervous stimulants amphetamines
and caffeine so when anyone tells you
that nootropics are AB fed amine or
caffeine or nootropics it's not there
they're not in the same category
you see nootropics is on its own noetic
activity meaning higher level like brain
activity so they have piracetam
at arrest and because there's also those
effects afterward within photo means and
with caffeine is yeah well they're just
regulating up your like fight-or-flight
thing in my book and in the full slides
I have there's a book called blitzed
about them about the Nazis taking them
feta means something called promotin and
then it makes your fight-or-flight go up
and so they made them much better
soldiers cuz they're like on the edge of
their seat like firing which is not what
you want
that's actually the like story in my
book about how drug development could go
wrong yeah and then like I nootropics
are like the savior of it so this is
just like the cat trying to categorize
it was difficult and so they had to
propose and next the own topic next
slide no that's not my book that's the
Cornelia Girja that's that's
fundamentals of pharmacology mine which
is there's only two known copies that
are outside of library and I own both of
them that's one of them talking about
your book my book was a history of the
tropics so this this this was like laid
out with all these studies you can find
all the charts like towards about
fundamentals to a farmer cornelia gorgeo
he was a hungarian neuropharmacology is
in belgium some of his writings like in
french some of it like this stuff we're
talking about was like towards the back
over here there's like the cat EG and
piracetam so that was like the most full
description of the nootropic concept and
like where they were going with it and
so they basically basically this is from
the first paper he said a new class is
therefore considered for what you
proposed a term we trope
nice meeting mind and troop and meaning
towards so they mean towards the minds
to class that selectively enhances
higher-level integrative activity you
know there's a compound related to
vanilla that's why old books smell good
when they break down and get that
vanilla smell that's the calm I forget
the name of it it's related to vanilla
that's why old books smell good [ __ ]
logo there's like 200 something
compounds in vanilla but which is ironic
cuz we think of it as a bland flavor but
it's very complex when did he this is
19th 1972 and then this cooks back to
the whole brain evolution
he's a pin field will derp infield was
his researcher who says this integrative
activity is probably the main factor in
evolution towards Homo sapiens so this
is where it like links back to that
first slide the evolution of our brain
and higher level cognitive activity and
this is like where the human brain is
saying that evolution has not like in
the last 50,000 years our brain has not
evolved it takes millions of years
hundreds of thousands potentially to
fully evolve our brain so he has a quote
I believe do we have a quote man will
not wait passively for millions of years
I don't know if we have it but it says
man will not wait passage for millions
of years for evolution off from a better
brain and that's the concept that truly
drives me in nootropics is that we have
to take evolution of our brain in hand
like yes I take DHA and all that but we
actually need to like activate our
higher-level activity to include more
neurons to stimulate neurogenesis and
synaptogenesis yeah making new synapses
making new neurons which can be done
chemically new pep has been shown to
raise BDNF which is a battle which is
brain derived neurotrophic factor which
is like a growth factor of how many
neurons your brain is demanding and its
factory to make and so that's the kind
of thing if we can it's like going to
the gym if you go to the gym but you
don't eat protein you'll just catabolize
you'll take muscle and protein other
parts your body and just put it like in
your bicep but if you add exogenously
and just have like a you know point
eight to one point three grams of grams
of protein per pound of bodyweight
you'll be able to gain muscle mass just
from working out if you rip a muscle and
then you your body will synthesize new
ones so that's why when you take
nootropics you want to do like their
studies showing brain training plus
nootropics is better than brain training
ordered trip
alone so we want to like so you want to
take exogenously human mind things that
seems like yeah evolution isn't just
gonna sit around or not I mean we're not
gonna wait for humans to evolve get a
better brain evolved we can actually
take science by the horns and them and
and on top of that the brain is like is
a powerful as more powerful than the
most powerful supercomputer we have yet
it runs on the power of a light bulb I
gave a talk and a half and half the
conference called hacking the most
powerful supercomputer in the universe
is about the brain and the idea is is
that the brain had to be able to operate
when it had minimal things like if it
didn't it's a choline for example if you
roll the next slide well I'll go to in a
second you go one slide forward I
believe so we have choline yeah so
choline is a precursor for acetylcholine
and so oh leans in choline it's either
choline is the other ingredient in both
those pills so that's like makes the
stat so that's why profound effects
combining choline and porosity so we
have like a more advanced porosity and
the purist patented cognizance eita
choline imported from Japan made in a
bioreactor that's a freebase and not a
salt like that it's not patented it's a
salt form so this is like pure brain
fuel just taking that in like a few
minutes okay just taking that in human
and human adult's like women especially
postmenopausal women will increase their
cognitive abilities in 28 days and
healthy adult and healthy males it also
works the idea is that everybody needs
about 500 milligrams of choline a day
and the Kolar genetic system helps
firing it runs through the hippocampus
it makes us for memory taking Prats so
just taking this the process the choline
alone will keep it in the straddle areas
if you have the racetam the piracetam
the new pep the phenol piracetam the
real nootropics they're like the the gas
pedal telling your body to use that tank
of new acetylcholine and choline and
bring it into the hippocampus we're
forming memory so that's kind of like
this stack and there's a synergy between
them if you hit the next slide you'll
see this is you know your [ __ ]
which is range important thank you
hopefully to the US of pre-trade it's a
new field like you were describing
really recent fairly relative field
especially in healthy people which will
go back a couple slides in a minute to
those but so I was Saline that was a
control after they've been training here
was choline alone
there's porosity I'm alone come Pat
prostitution choline look how the
difference the magnitude effect and it
was so that it they think in this case
because these were like dementia
population is that they're cooler genic
normal memory system is Adam WAC and
just providing the choline won't help
them because you don't have the
regulation and the enhancement of the
brain that the piracetam and the
nootropic provides so in these
population it's like one more time on
the difference between the piracetam how
it puts the foot on the gas pedal in the
cold yeah helpless so choline is a fuel
for acetylcholine acetylcholine this
type of choline we have also donates
lipids to help the brain make new
neurons don't sell every cell has C the
choline or phosphatidylcholine in it
which comes directly from this precursor
source so the choline supply no Genesis
cellular yeah to make new cells also
neurogenesis but the choline is like the
fuel that builds up the like supply and
then the piracetam with an entropic if
you know whatever phenol process a more
say piracetam like nootropic is the gas
pedal telling your brain it's okay to go
a little bit faster we have all this
fuel implement that in and let's gun it
up and then your brain can it's not
worried about the dietary limitations of
precursors ok so there's an increase in
supplying than the gas penalty yes to go
with it so you don't want to step on the
gas pedal like an amphetamine steps on
the gas pedal of dopamine without giving
you like tyrosine to help build back up
the pressure so this also like brings it
to the area that otherwise it would stay
in the straddle outside areas ok so
that's what you got right here is
choline that's what choline impressed
him those profound effects are found in
these pills hopefully you go back to
slides now here we have the increase in
the power of human memory a normal
manner so this was the first study this
is a study that started the like whole
smart drugs thing this is back in 1976
this is the first time that any drug
really ever was shown to enhance healthy
brains these college students were given
per asset am and they by the second week
this is 0 days 7 days 14 days they were
verbal their recall their verbal recall
was dramatically improved statistically
significantly improved so they're like
what the heck and that's kind of like
where like I believe the like pop
culture and that was like the first wave
of cognitive enhancers kind of came in I
believe we're now like in the second
wave of smart drugs and nootropics and
cognitive enhancers but if you go
forward now a couple slides we're gonna
hear all of those students longer yeah I
don't know what having them but so they
kept more time they kept experimenting
with nootropics and they're like what
because it has all these properties
because it's extremely safe because it
protects the brain and brings back
normal activity when it's disrupted
they're like this is like one of the
create wilder ones is they did piracetam
inject it into a pregnant mother in
labor or a c-section because the baby in
there is not getting enough oxygen to
its brain so they either have to operate
or they could give the mother prostate
which would go into the baby's brain and
when it went to the baby's brain this is
humans and this is live adult alive live
babies they recovered more quickly with
the piracetam than a c-section but so
they made fun of Preston oh yeah they
made fun of piracetam saying this is a
drug and such and depletions going on in
the in a fetus that's not being stuck in
the womb but not able to come at him but
the same way those rats were covered
more quickly when it had PRASA time when
they were suffocated Wow it protected
the baby it's very interesting yeah and
so they use it for in surgery they would
give it to you to come conscious more
quickly they try to in dyslexia
development ill distribute eventually
people are like this is a drug and
surgeries they would make fun of it but
other scientists are like we need to
move from the question of efficacy this
[ __ ] works we need to say where it could
be you you there where's the therapeutic
relevancy and so that's difficult in
healthy adults there's no category
medically to use that clinically and so
you cannot use them to get funding for
like drug development and anything as as
something and aid for healthy people and
so where it worked well because our
Koller genetic systems already flowing
well and that's one of the things that
facilitates it doesn't show like you
can't use that to say like hey we're
gonna enhance these people already
healthy so it kind of was like lost for
if you go to the next slide you'll see
that the in and so in this intervening
time in the next 20 years there's an
evolution of piracetam where they try to
make different ones and so here we have
aniracetam which is like a creative is
important I would say creative shorter
lasting nootropic you have Occitan which
is kind of works better for some people
for some reason has a sweet taste pram
'is a more physical one less cognitive
and then lever asset am was became an
epilepsy drug and that's actually why
this company stopped working on
piracetam because lever racetam had the
same energy and electrical activity
regulating properties of the brain
without the cognitive effects which we
consider a side effect it's actually
negative and clinical things you can't
explain in effect it's not good so they
got one without cognitive properties
that still regulated the electrical
activity of the brain and they became a
blockbuster anti epilepsy drug and it is
its own class of epilepsy drugs in the
way in which it works yeah and then so
here's new pep and phenol problems and
with epilepsy the level racetam yeah you
can walk and check it out if you have
epilepsy so then they made i'm going
faster we're short on time here but so
new pepper phenol piracetam were then
made actually and both of them were made
in different labs in Russia you know
piracetam was because they wanted one
for russian cosmonauts astronauts in
space Russian astronauts in space to
increase their physical activity without
cracking them out because there's this
little tiny thing also say there was a
loss of oxygen in the space pod what's
gonna help their brain go back to normal
better
piracetam also if you're slowly losing
oxygen are being poisoned by like carbon
dioxide you go mentally insane and so
this would prevent the disruption if
something happened and the longest
spacewalk at the time in the early 90s
was 179 days and the astronaut was on
funeral piracetam during his trip and
then new pet was made because they want
and it fetal process a of his band for
Olympic athletes and in the IOC
International Olympic Committee and
world anti-doping agency for these are
again considered if you're going for the
cognitive properties these would be side
effects is increased endurance and
physical and resistance to cold so those
like the side cool side effects so that
one's why I say that ones like more
physical and it gives you like greater
away
in space and new pet is a dipeptide form
so peptides a short chain of amino acids
but they're very easily for the body to
absorb and peptides or dye peptides are
stronger so that you can see they move
the porosity there's piracetam plus a
phenyl group there's a prostitue him
here's a paratha Tim went on two sides
of this molecule onto like a structural
component of the brain VAT what's called
vasopressin and it's considered a
thousand times stronger by molecular
weight and it also has like anti-anxiety
and anxiolytics properties as they call
so they're like this things more
powerful and it has a side effect of
like getting you more Zin and that one
is extensively studied in people with
post-concussion to help like regrow the
brain and like repair and also for pre
dementia people to like keep them going
well so people say like what are the
hood actually prevents the onset of
disease yeah so yeah there's a study and
so this is what people say is what's the
long-term effects of nootropics and it's
like there's a study one year-long
placebo-controlled double-blind happen
the placebo were given 14 different
psychometric tests like tests our brain
activity what's today's date what's this
going on do this math problem what's the
shape I just told you two questions ago
stuff like that and the people were on
Pratt not on the placebo they went down
a nine out of the 14 these are pre
dementia so they're like six fifty and
sixty and they're aging over this year
and there had to be have some issue that
they're starting to realize their brain
is going if they were in the study the
people on piracetam only went down on
one that's pretty yeah it's pretty nut
so I'm gonna say what's the long-term
effects that's when I say if we don't
end aging or die trying' like our brain
is gonna decline so like our only
hypothesis is that our brains are gonna
go so we can protect our brains we
should be taking atrophic as early as
possible potentially so we're gonna look
real quickly at unifrom and sunna Framm
and the next slide which is basically
like how we kind of like got to the
biohacker like how how do tropics came
to me again like through the internet
and so this is as uniform and sunnah
frame our partner molecules unify is the
the name of the University in Florence
it's like the college name symbol name
like if UCLA unify is University of
Florence and so this guy was studying
nootropic derivatives in around 2008
found this like whole class and he had
all these properties but because of the
financial crisis they stopped the
development they didn't patent it all
these things and this scientist is
sitting there years later and he gets an
email from some of them the internet
saying hey like what's the optimal
dosing for humans for these sayings and
the guy's like what the hell is going on
and doesn't respond or anything and then
he gets a message from the guy like a
few months later saying hey I got some
of this stuff I'm taking this dose six
times a day for a total of that I've not
spent one second tired I've lured my
sleep and he and this scientist goes in
and Google's up compound he's like holy
[ __ ] you could buy this like I'm China
it's all available on the internet he's
like whoa like this has never been
tested in humans like the ones I have
have been testing humans I personally
don't take these because they don't have
extensive testing and post marketing
surveillance or they've been on the
market for 10 or 20 years things become
apparent but there are more experimental
things and so this guy is like fully
[ __ ] moving forward to fix yeah he's
thing from the lab to the web and he's
saying there's a shortcoming
academically and industrially we're like
this thing potentially is safe because
being used it could have worked but
because it impacted because of all these
things you know now I'm not making any
money on it it was lost to science the
potential for this thing and now it's
out there and it's like so that that is
showing these scientists are even aware
now that people are furthering their
research and taking it and having them
synthesized and they're going out there
so the bio hacker lab rats were willing
to experiment which taking these I
wouldn't say is a super experiment
because they like pretty much proven to
be safe but there are people who are
willing to take like crazy or outside
ones you can ask me about like c60
fullerenes and stuff if we have time and
the government is actually trying to
figure out how to put their feet in to
regulate their arms and to regulate but
at the same time that's difficult
because you don't want to impede
innovation you want to let people
biohacking science and figure I don't
know what their true stance is but these
things if they're safe and consenting
adults you know what they're taking
should be able to like try to augment
themselves positively they're being
drugged you think don't get you high
there's no dose that will like get you
high
like they're just they just are like to
help you be a better person and it'll be
a shame to ever have that stopped and so
I try to responsibly bring nootropic
to the world and to like have super pure
I don't use any fillers or excipient
sirs no like silica in there there's
literally like pure nootropics just
those ingredients and it's it takes a
lot of effort to get those there but I
have doctors offices buying them because
they don't want to go to a compounding
facility they can't even get this
formula so if you go to the next slide I
believe we're done with that this is
kind of the wrap up that to be a true
bio hacker and it really hit true
optimal performance it's not just about
taking this pill it's a it's about like
that brain training plus the pill like
the way the body builders like yeah
supplement plus the activity you need
card exactly exactly so you increase the
ATP energy turnover your brain which
PRASA tan will also increase you need
physical exercise you need mental
exercise some meditation he's dying I
recommend like a ketogenic diet
journyx fat is a much more stable fuel
getting sleep is when you do long-term
potentiation you transfer memories from
short-term to long-term you consolidate
the when your muscles are moving and
they burn they have lactic acid that can
be cleared out through the lymphatic
system we just discovered a couple years
ago something called the glymphatic
system similarly named in the brain
these channels that clear out and get
rid of the metabolites which cannot be
cleared like the muscles can do while
you're awake you have to be asleep now
that happens so you're gonna build up
junk in your brain if you don't sleep
plus a new pet has a charge on it that
makes little particles in your brain
clump together which then can then be
excavated from your brain by your like
your body's like brain the neutral
protocol I love it shape of an atom too
well looks like a five things you really
any of the ones you could do will help
but they're all like there's also like
exercise plus intro because meditation
plus exercise totally total all these
over last is a really crazy important
combination like you wrote here and made
it like that illustration a lot I
appreciate that are we on the way to
climb mitigation show yeah I believe
it's nets do it alright so so that's a
lot on nootropics and we covered you
know we did we did definitely did the
Cliff Notes version of nootropics but
your book will be out in the next few
months in the next few months the book
will be out there'll be part one the
history of nootropics and then you'll be
able to dive into more of kind of like
what's going on today and also with all
the like history of those molecules and
stuff is cool
so we got that coming out a few months
I'll be exciting and when when that goes
live will definitely be promoting as
well there'll be a lot of fun and then
okay so that's on nootropics and that's
on like you know guys like go and test
yourselves and like see what happens
when I'll give you a code for discount
for your what users as well we'll get it
just put simulation and I'll make it
simulation simulation as a dismissal
we'll be in the bio so definitely go and
take a try at what it feels like for all
of these last decades of research and
experience go and try it out now yes
you'll get acute effects short-term
single dose effects but the
statistically significant we see is
between seven and 14 days we give it a
whole month's worth to get the full full
story and three months yeah you gonna go
the real get into it so Eric's also very
Polymathic as you can tell he's not only
understanding about the human body and
the very deep nuances of the anatomy and
the physiology but he also cares a lot
about a ton of other things and so one
of the things that you've made is a
think tank to mitigate climate change
and this is anthropogenic climate change
yeah this is specifically us increasing
the cars per million of co2 specifically
and and so one of the things that you've
that you've discovered in climb
mitigation is this beautiful thing
called olivine and you have an which is
the Tree of Life which is awesome so now
olivine actually helps us us remove see
you so all of the yes so all of you is a
very common Rock it makes up 60 to 80
percent of the mantle and it's also the
birthstone the gemstone quality version
is known as peridot is the August
birthstone but what you may not know
about this rock which is seemingly
common is that when it is exposed to
process called weathering is when the
rock meets the environment there's co2
humidity water erosion is a part of this
this process as well in the weathering
of the rock there's a reaction with
olivine with co2 that creates a
bicarbonate solution so it takes the co2
implements into this alkaline solution
and that event depending on where it is
example if you put these rocks in the
ocean if they're when they're ground up
they will sequester carbon and
eventually into the clay and sand soil
on the sea floor and so what's
interesting is that ninety-nine point
percent of carbon in the world not co2
but carbon the element is actually
already in rock I don't have a little
chart here but I like that limestone
yeah sure I should have got off your
limestone and like dolomite dolomite yes
good call dolomite it's because of the
price yeah there you go you got that
your brain fire in there yes so the rock
is mostly sequestering all the carbon on
earth already so it makes a lot of sense
to put it back in there and so we know
that the process of weathering of
olivine especially when its accelerated
can change the temperature because the
current current cooling glycation period
that we're in which we are causing a
warming but as a macro trend we are in a
cooling period in the global time scale
when the Himalayan mountains and the
Tibet Plateau raised up it actually
exposed so much of this rock of olivine
and a type of rock that it caused a
global cooling and so we know it works
on a global scale to modify the
temperature and so that's so nuts okay
so now all of them can actually be laid
out over 2% of the world's most active
ocean front exactly it would take a
volume of seven kilometers cubed of
olivine poured onto the world's 2% most
active beaches part of it is that every
if you had to grind up the rock itself
that co2 would be calculated away from
your ultimate sequestration of co2 so
we're gonna use free tidal waves the
type title energy and the wave motion to
grind up the olivine this is a natural
oils requestor co2 into the rock into
the seafloor and then Mike things like
lugworms and these things on the
seafloor will eat it and then they poop
out basically limestone rock they poop
out like rock that eventually settles
into like the ground and so that's
there's three other thing three things
that does so it's so that carbonate
solution is alkaline so it also D
acidifies the ocean in the immediate
area and
one of the other breakdown metabolites
which when it is all there further
process or its silica which becomes
silicate which is a limiting factor for
diatoms which are a form of plankton
which are like the few food for the full
ecosystem and food chain is the basis of
the food chain so you have a basis for
marine food chain or a fall so
photosynthesis
yes exactly there the fact of how we
actually have oxygen to breathe seventy
percent of it comes exactly so you get
that I haven't calculated in full a
phytoplankton effect or that has not
been calculated cuz there's a number of
scientific papers we put olivine
weathering olivine for sequestration
carbon sequestration and ocean
acidification there's a number of papers
that this project is based off of and
they've done the math all the way out
pricing a ton pricing a ton of olivine
from the port of rotterdam for 23 euros
and they believe at scale you could get
it down to 10 euros per ton each ton of
olivine that breaks down sequester's
1.25 tonnes of carbon so the average
American puts out around 18 to 20 tons
of carbon a year damn that be like a
hundred and eighty dollars to two
hundred something dollars just to get
rid of your whole carbon yeah yeah
that's that's pretty good it's kind of
cool because the other options like
carbon capture and like is is around
forty to fifty two hundred dollars per
ton per ton and so that's what the Paris
climate Accord is based off of and so
we're pretty much screwed if that is the
only solution we have and so we need
cheaper carbon sequestration kurtz
people say like what about growing trees
maybe the trees will sequester carbon
and especially the first few years but
then you have to monitor those trees
from past parasites fire those trees
then burn all that 50 years you spent
sequestering it's going to go back in
you actually after like grow the trees
cut them and they like put them in a
mine underground which is actually like
how our trees originally how we
originally got oil and coal deposits
were in the early parts of the world
there was no fungi to break down trees
the ligands and the tree and so trees
piled up and then they eventually got
crushed under pressure and then volcanic
activity made them into coal coal it's
actually like that is we're just
repeating the same process so I don't
know how to do that I think that like if
we could get cyu to a whole climate
again you
whole think-tank around mitigating
climate change human cost climate change
and how to do this and again you are
very articulate about knowing your [ __ ]
regarding this ok so then there's
climate ocation and then you're just in
general a very or next slide yeah yeah
let's show the next slide it's just a
rock break yeah that was like them
rolling abroad that was a natural Beach
by the way papakolea in Hawaii which
from volcanic activity has green sand
already we know it's safe with what's
gonna happen is the beach that will make
will be a tourist attraction as well so
let's go visit this Beach we're gonna
sell necklaces like this and other ones
that will it'll be like 200 bucks and
will offset your whole year co2
they're very inspiration to because
people get a walk around and say this is
what sequester's carbon so it becomes a
conversational piece comes about a
belief a belief that we can that we can
reverse climate change because it gives
us hope that's the point yes and yeah
exactly now now there's what olivine
actually looks like after it gets round
and polished after the motion as well
okay so that's climb mitigation and
project Vesta and we'll put again links
in the bio for people to check out
called project Vesta cos for Vesta is a
second largest proto planet body in the
asteroid belt and it is happens to be
made of all of you and so sorry about
that all of you if they would call twice
it's going through I guess the olivine
is is is what earth formed from those
rocks that body was what earth crashed
together and that's where like a lot of
our olivine came from so it's pretty
neat so okay so now you also had the
pleasure of working on a team that was
put together through reddit to work on
the Hyperloop project you authored
medium post called X without y yes I'm a
futurist as well you know looking at the
future I love technology and like part
of the reason I want to live a long time
is so I can see the technological
likewise change I mean that's also one
of the reasons I want to people say
aren't you all over like no because if
I'm gonna live 150 200 years or
something I'm gonna have to deal with
the planet that we're creating today and
so it's not my grandchildren's problems
that my great great great role it's my
problem so when you littered
cup when you release that co2 that's
some co2 I'm gonna have to work on
sucking back in and so I it is all
integrated where it's like if you want
to live a long time and the last thing
to go would be your brain I want to
protect the brain if the planets gonna
be a problem I want to protect the
planet so these are all kind of
integrated into being you know future
forward thinking very long now
perspective it's a long now perspective
slow ticks of the clock but I want to
make sure that I the world in the future
is desirable and I have my brain to
enjoy it and I'm not like an old
decrepit person she's also like why a
biohack and take you know some more
advanced things we are two futurists
here on the show yes you are good
futurist building that bright powerful
future for everyone now this X without
why you and I hilariously when we were
at this is July wrote this article in
July 18 2016 because I was going to the
Indy bio demo days which are
biotechnology accelerator and they had
like after I would I've been for the two
years for the two or three demo days
prior which is one every six months and
I kept seeing this like there was like
cows and they were taking cells from
them then generating me based on that so
there's like meat without the cow and
they're using like a mushroom till I
grow like a leather like materials like
leather without account then they had
breast milk in a bioreactor without a
breast and so you had you had wine with
the dirt analyzing the chemistry of the
wine and then just making it just wine
without great sounds like wow this is an
internist as a time two years ago when
uber Forex and blah blah blah was like
such a business model we have the maids
were uber fer you know there were maids
for like so that uber Forex model was
very prominent and I was like well I see
this new model in biotech the winner
which is like X without Y like that
breast milk without the breast the
leather cows and there's a bunch of
other examples in wood without trees
which shows in two years later I'm at
the ring and these guys are using like
in ligands of a certain type of flaxseed
yeah good remember you have the flax and
they're like stringing it out and you
can make just like care of its like cast
out of wood fibers are super strong it's
amazing and I look at their freaking
there's taglines of wood we got trees so
as a futurist to see a prediction come
to fruition it was like very meta for me
and it's I love that and it's like when
you're predicting the future or putting
something out there you don't know that
it's gonna come true that's cut you're
almost like speculating it away or
making an observation that may may or
may not be like a real thing per se but
it has proven to be now this real
observations
yeah and that's always great as a
futurist putting something out there and
then seeing factually comes true in the
next couple months or years and there it
is that's kind of like the Hyperloop
stuff if you go back for the Hyperloop
let's rap let's let's rap on that's real
quickly rap on that because it's about
the food yeah the Hyperloop pod is a was
a set in passing by Elon Musk at a talk
he was giving a fireside chat about how
he's stuck in traffic and he imagined
this like v mode of transportation and
so people got hyped on it and eventually
they like proposed a student competition
people on reddit in the comments section
on SpaceX said hey I think we could do
this and we made like a slack channel
and then we've got over 150 people and
this is two years after that we were we
had were the only non-student people
left from from a thousand applicants to
132 a design competition 220 people
winning the design competition we were
one of them so this is two years later
bringing our pod to SpaceX headquarters
to compete and so I always say an anon
student-organized distributed around the
world
15 20 country teams like engineers
people stay and it was amazing like and
when this this headline is separate from
this image when we met at the design
competition it was the first time when I
went and got a guy flew in from India
never been to the US before and nobody
on the team had ever met in person I
wouldn't find him because he was like
where am i and we got him here's the
first time anyone met there's a picture
in that article but and this is to end
on this is that so interesting being a
futurist people say why are you doing
the Hyperloop what's the point of it
like you're not a business it's not even
a business like how are you you know
what why what is the point I go one day
when I'm riding in a Hyperloop I'm gonna
know the future is here because this
technology was invented under my
and I helped in some small way make this
come to fruition totally and so that is
like the idea being a futurist is like
to help of my job is to help accelerate
the future forward to bring us the
future more rapidly and there's like I
call this thing and one of my writings
called the slack now we're in this this
this time like slack and I liken it to
be and I'll leave it with this metaphor
is like being behind a boat and when
you're there you get the water skis up
and you're like you're sitting there and
you got that three-legged you give a
thumbs up to the boat like I'm ready to
go but in that moment you're still
sinking down there and you're slacking
the line and it's not tighten the boat
it's taking off you can see the boat is
moved but you're there like sinking and
it seems like you're in the worst time
like you're about to drown you're like
struggling to Bob your head above water
and then suddenly the slack pulls out a
line and you're now hydroplaning like
magic above the water and so I believe
that we're in like a technological slack
where our inventions and our things that
we're making have not caught up to the
reality that we exist in today - that
will bring those technologies forward
and so part of the way you can beat that
bring this you know take the slack of
the line is to pull the work shorter and
so as a futurist in terms of bringing
this information out there and helping
people like experienced the future they
when they believe the future's here in
these there's like a new aesthetic of
the future like having even a futuristic
haircut it makes them look futuristic
when you look around you want it to be
futuristic and so that's kind of like as
a futurist the goal is to help pull the
slack out of line and I think here at
simulation you're doing that and I try
to do that myself I think you do and I
think you do a great job of it and it's
always a pleasure to be able to host
very multidisciplinary people on the
show and that's why I'm very grateful to
have you as my friend and as someone
that is building the future and you're
doing that with new troe do you know how
to climb it again I did that with the
Hyperloop so it's a pleasure to have you
on the show thank you thank you so much
for coming on the show we'll have to get
to some of the other simulation
questions at another time that will be a
lot of fun so just to review everyone
will have a promo code in the bio for
you to order up some nootropics
from neutral and give it a go and let us
know your thoughts we'd love to hear
about it also do check out climb
mitigation join the think-tank as well
subscribe join our family with
simulation and leave us a comment of
what you thought share the content with
other people around you we'd love to get
more people talking and building with
this so whether you go out and create
with it so go make a video about it
going write about it go and talk to
other people about to start a company
about it you know go do your thing go
create with it and join us on patreon if
you'd like we really need to continue
help supporting the studio and growing
this process so that would be greatly
appreciated thanks everyone
much love Ron Vargas are producing
partner and director all right everyone
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you